[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire les entreprises doivent
elles faire un effort sur les salaires
grâce aux aides versées depuis le début
de la crise due qu'aux fidèles ont pu
globalement maintenir leurs marges pour
le ministre de l'économie bruno le maire
la bonne croissance 6% prévus cette
année doit profiter à tout le monde il
faut une meilleure rémunération de ceux
qui ont les revenus les plus faibles
pourtant les salaires n'augmentent
guerre ni en france ni ailleurs en
europe on s'attend à une hausse de 0,6
pour cent en moyenne cette année pour
les employés et pour les cadres les
salariés sont ils les grands perdants
des 30 dernières années comme on le dit
souvent est ce le et cela peut-il et
doit-il changer pour en débattre nous
avons inventé invité françois xavier
haut niveau vous avez 20 ans
d'expérience dans la direction
d'activités de conseils et vous êtes
l'auteur de la crise de l'abondance paru
aux édition de l'observatoire l'humanité
n'ait jamais été aussi riche dites vous
dans ce livre en vie dans ce que nos
ancêtres considéré comme une utopie
irréalisable
le problème c'est qu'on a l'habitude de
gérer la pénurie pas l'abondance d'où
les crises à répétition alors d'après
vous faut-il que les entreprises fassent
un effort sur les salaires si elle pense
que c'est pertinent pourquoi pas ben ça
dépend de leur compétitivité de leur
état ne par rapport à la concurrence
c'est une décision libre de chaque chef
d'entreprise aurélie trouvez-vous ses 20
ans d'expérience au coeur des mouvements
sociaux enseignante chercheuse en
économie ingénieur agronome porte parole
d'attac vous êtes l'auteur du livre le
bloc arc en ciel qui vient de paraître à
la découverte pour vous l'exigence
d'égalité réelle exprimée par les deux
mines est en train de bouleverser
l'ordre établi
fragmentée jusqu'à présent elle pourrait
si elle s'unit sait faire trembler les
fondations de la société bourgeoise je
vous cite vous il faut que les
entreprises fassent un effort
il faut oui et donc pour ça il faut une
décision politique donc c'est pas c'est
pas au libre choix il faut aujourd'hui
augmenter le smic beaucoup plus que ce
que fait aujourd'hui le gouvernement qui
en fait ne l'augmentent pas il ne fait
que suivre l'inflation et c'est une
question de justice sociale mais aussi
d'efficacité macroéconomiques pour pour
la création d'emplois parce qu'en fait
pour relancer les consommations il faut
au contraire augmenter le smic ce qui
permettra d'augmenter le pouvoir d'achat
et donc de remplir les carnets de
commandes jean-eudes du mesnil vous êtes
secrétaire général de la scpp la
confédération des petites et moyennes
entreprises des cpm
une organisation patronale représentant
environ 243 bis l'entreprise employant 4
millions de salariés tous secteurs
confondus est ce que les entreprises
doivent faire un effort sur les salaires
les entreprises lorsqu'elles le peuvent
évidemment font des efforts sur les
salaires malheureusement tout ne le
peuvent pas et puis quand on parle
pouvoir d'achat c'est pas simplement les
salaires il ya d'autres moyens
d'augmenter le pouvoir d'achat des
français sans impacter la compétitivité
des entreprises donc il faut trouver le
bon équilibre et ce qui a été dit tout à
l'heure évidemment je le partage la
décision appartient à chaque chef
d'entreprise en fonction de la situation
propre à l'entreprise
alors avant d'aborder le coeur du débat
qui est justement là où vous n'êtes pas
tous d'accord est-ce que ça doit
dépendre des entreprises des chefs
d'entreprises ou de l'état est ce que
est ce que les salariés sont vraiment
les grands perdants des trente dernières
années
comme on le dit souvent françois-xavier
haut niveau au détriment des
actionnaires par exemple si on est
trente dernières années on a vu le le
capital prenait plus en plus de place
dans la production de valves de richesse
et le travail de moins en moins
effectivement etc mais c'est une
tendance de fond en fait ça fait en fait
deux cents ans que la machine remplace
en tout cas une partie des sommes sûrs
sur une partie de leurs fonctions ce qui
est à la fois de libération on le fait
on est beaucoup plus riche et beaucoup
on a beaucoup plus de temps que ce qu'on
avait au 10ème siècle temps de travail
au cours d'une vie a considérablement
baissé depuis depuis 200 ans on est
passé de 40 50 % d'une veillée ya une
douzaine 2% seulement et il continue à
baisser il va continuer à baisser parce
que la machine va continuer à nous à la
fois nous remplacer nous libérer donc à
une transition qui est très difficile à
vivre mais qui fait qu effectivement sur
certaines fonctions le marché va avoir
de plus en plus de mal à rémunérer
effectivement certains travaillent
travaux aurélie trouvé
est en fait c'est pas une tendance de
200 ans parce que il ya une vraie une
vraie rupture dans les années 80 certes
le partage de cette fameuse valeur
ajoutée produite par les entreprises on
peut on peut en économiquement la
diviser et entre ce qui va pour les
actionnaires ce qui va pour les
investissements et l'emploi et ce qui va
pour les actions la part de cette
richesse qui va vers les actionnaires
est de plus en plus importante depuis
les années 80 il ya une vraie rupture et
est de moins en moins importante vers
l'investissement et surtout vers
l'emploi vers vers le paiement des
salaires si vous voulez et ça c'est lié
au tournant néolibéral c'est à dire que
pendant les trente glorieuses des années
50 aux années 80 il ya bien eu quand
même un pacte qui permettait dans
l'économie de rémunérer en tout cas
d'avoir une part de plus en plus
importante qu'à l'hiver le salaire et
les emplois et ça ça a été classée dans
les années 80 et c'est de pire en pire
donc on a aujourd'hui voilà une richesse
qui va de plus en plus vers les
dividendes vers les grands actionnaires
avec y compris des mesures prises durant
ce quinquennat qui renforce cela je
pense par exemple au fait de ne plus
place de plafonner pardon la fiscalité
sur les revenus financiers
tout un tas de mesures qui finalement
prises par ce gouvernement notamment qui
finalement favorise encore plus ce
partage de la valeur ajoutée de la
richesse globale faire les dividendes et
les actionnaires et on peut d'ailleurs
voir aussi que sur la dernière depuis un
an d'ailleurs cette explosion des
dividendes et est très manifeste est ce
qui est donc inquiétant c'est qu'en plus
il ya crise sanitaire en fait à
accélérer ce phénomène de de répartition
en faveur des actionnaires est en
défaveur des salariés qui aujourd'hui
crée aussi une explosion des inégalités
de richesse puisque on voit que et bien
les les milliardaires les très très
riches plus globalement les 0,01 cent
les plus riches sont plus en plus riches
et donc les inégalités sociales
augmentent j'arrive du mesnil
malheureusement il ya assez peu de
patrons de pme dans les milliardaires
dans les richesses augmente est-ce qu'il
faut bien quand même comprendre c'est la
structuration du tissu économique
français j'entendais parler de grandes
entreprises de grand capital il faut
bien avoir en tête aujourd'hui en france
il ya simplement 5000 entreprises sur à
peu près 3 milles en 3 millions
d'entreprises au total qui ont plus de
250 salariés donc quand j'entends parler
de répartition entre les actionnaires et
les salariés dans les pme je vous
garantis que il ya une communauté
d'intérêts entre le chef d'entreprise et
ses salariés
ensemble ils regardent comment évolue le
carnet de commandes et leur
préoccupation c'est évidemment de
développer l'entreprise de la sauver
dans certains cas ça a été le cas
notamment pendant la période de vide et
surtout de faire en sorte que
collectivement cette entreprise
obtiennent de nouveaux marchés et dans
la mesure du possible du rémunérer les
salariés en conséquence en fonction de
la situation réelle de l'entreprise est
ce que vous estimez pour autant que dans
l'est dans les pme les salariés n'ont
pas été les grands perdants de ces
trente dernières années
je crois pas qu'on puisse dire ça d'une
manière générale moi ce que je sais
c'est qu'il ya certains c'est d'abord
vous faut distinguer en fonction de la
taille des entreprises ou les 10 il faut
distinguer en fonction des secteurs
d'activité et c'est certain que quand
vous êtes dans une entreprise par
exemple de transport routier que le taux
de marge globale du secteur c'est 2% il
est bien évident que la moindre dépense
supplémentaire impact la marge de
l'entreprise et est susceptible de la
mettre en péril donc augmenter les
salaires quand c'est possible oui mais
encore une fois je le répète
malheureusement c'est pas possible d'une
manière générale après y'a il ya d'autre
systèmes qu'on pourrait observer par
exemple le décalage entre le salaire net
et le salaire brut
on aurait moyen là de faire quelque
chose pour réduire cet écart entre
salaire net et salaire brut pour donner
davantage de pouvoir d'achat aux
salariés sans impacter négativement la
compétitivité des entreprises donc c'est
ces pistes là sans doute qu'il faut
explorer pour augmenter le pouvoir
d'achat des salariés encore une fois je
le répète sans mettre en danger des
entreprises aurélie trouvé deux cités
comme le phénix oxfam par exemple les
les salaires des pdg du cac 40 qui
gagnerait
250 fois le salaire moyen
de leurs deux qui existent dans leur
entreprise est ce que c'est de bon
exemple c'est comme quand vous parlez
des milliardaires ils sont pas nombreux
les milliardaires ils sont mille sur
toute la planète est-ce que c'est
véritablement en fonction d'eux qu'on
doit tous tous réfléchir est-ce que ce
est ce que à force on ne confond pas les
riches les favoris v avec les ultras
risques qui sont une minorité
microscopique
alors
précisément il ya une concentration des
richesses surtout sur les ultra-riches
les 0 01 % et les derniers chiffres de
l'insee le montre un sur les derniers
chiffres de l'insee sur les 0,01 % les
plus riches
c'est
pardon c'est les derniers chiffres donc
sont 2018 est ce qui est montré c'est
que les 0 0 1% les plus riches gagné 34
fois le smic en 2015 et gagne 46 fois le
smic en 2018 donc il ya + 40 % de
revenus en trois ans et à linverse on a
pour le smic + 3 % donc voilà sur trois
ans on a + 40 % pour les 0 0 1% les plus
riches + 3 % pour le smic un genre je
reviens à cette fameuse hausse du smic
comme vous venez de le dire ils sont
0,01 pour cent alors que les gens qui
gagnent le smic en france sont je crois
un peu plus de 4 millions donc à quick
ça sert de les comparer sauf que la
fiscalité sur les plus riches peut
permettre d'abord de rapporter des
recettes publiques très importante pour
les services publics
voilà nous par exemple la suppression de
l'sf plus la flat tax qui permet de
plafonner les revenus financiers tout
toutes ces mesures là on qui ont été
vraiment favorable aux 0 01 cent les
plus riches c'est entre 5 et 10
milliards de pertes de recettes fiscales
par an rien que ça et puis nous
évidemment propose aussi à ataka 1re un
impôt sur le revenu beaucoup plus
progressif et est beaucoup plus qu'ils
taxent beaucoup plus les très riches
tout ça permet de rapporter des recettes
publiques en plus dont on manque tant je
rappelle que pour les hôpitaux publics
les soignants les organisations de
soignants estime cependant qu'à peu près
de 100000 emplois pérennes dans les
hôpitaux publics à l'heure d'une très
grave et sanitaires quand on nous dit
qu'il n'ya pas assez d'argent les
hôpitaux publics bien sûr que si on peut
le récupérer par une fiscalité beaucoup
plus redistributive qui taxe beaucoup
plus les très riches et ça peut
rapporter je vous dis 10,23 milliards
d'euros par an plus une taxe sur les
transactions financières qui permettrait
aussi de diminuer la spéculation et il
ya deux fonctions à l'impôt qui sont
très importantes le partage des
richesses et pouvoir récupérer des
recettes publiques pour les services
publics pour la transition écologique
également qui permettrait de créer par
ailleurs des milliers des milliers
d'emplois à la fois dans la fonction
publique mais aussi en aidant les
entreprises privées sous de façon
conditionné donc cet argent public et
les précieux et a pour le coup pour le
en l'occurrence on peut tout à fait
taxer beaucoup plus les riches et je
pense que voilà c'est ce serait une
mesure de justice sociale qui serait qui
permettrait de par ailleurs de répondre
à des besoins sociaux écologiques
auxquels aujourd'hui on ne répond pas ça
que c'est bien au niveau je sais pas si
tu es cette histoire est vraie mais un
milliardaire américain qui on disait on
va tous vous prendre avait donné une
pièce de 10 cents à son interlocuteur en
lui disant ben voilà votre part est ce
que l on véritablement si on prenait
tous milliardaires est ce que
véritablement ça changerait le niveau de
vie des autres alors surtout ce qu'il
faut bien garder en tête c'est que il
faut quand même qu'on continue à
produire de la richesse avant de penser
à diviser le gâteau faut surtout
s'assurer et j'enjoins une usine là
dessus que l'entreprise et est
compétitive qu'elle peut être en
concurrence avec c'est avec ces acéré
que ccc des concurrents dans d'autres
pays et aujourd'hui le tissu économique
français il n'est pas très concurrentiel
il n'est pas très compétitifs dont il
faut surtout ne pas casser la machine
avant de penser à distribuer le gâteau
après un grand pdg du cac 40 qui est qui
et qui effectivement on peut être choqué
par la rémunération mais on peut on peut
aimer j'ai ça il faut quand même savoir
qui travaille beaucoup plus pour l'état
pour lui de dire le niveau de
prélèvements sociaux à la fois par les
par la cotisation sociale et par la
tranche marginale à 45% en fait qu'il
est il travaille aussi beaucoup
aujourd'hui pour pour l'état comment
est-ce qu'on peut réduire les inégalités
parce que l'eau là où aurélie trouvé a
raison c'est qu'il ya eu comme un
creusement des inégalités il ya une
tendance la brawn ans est assez
inégalitaire la maintenance concret et à
sénégal terre c'est l'une des crises qui
est provoqué par l'abondance avec deux
effets le premier c'est qu'effectivement
il ya d une polarisation de certains
salaires et certaines fonctions
qui fait que les des gens à qui vont
apporter une très forte valeur ajoutée
sur de l'intelligence artificielle sur
la technologie sûre de la donner à voir
des salaires qui vont monter
considérablement
les salaires manuels techniques restent
assez se tiennent pas mal parce que
finalement on a encore besoin de gens
pour conduire les camions aujourd'hui
une vraie crise aujourd'hui autour de
autour de prendre des conducteurs de
poids lourds une vraie crise autour
effectivement du personnel médical on
n'a rien dit à ce qui leur manque il en
manque absolument autour des gens qui se
travaille dans les cafés hôtels
restaurants notamment serveurs et
cuisiniers dont il ya des métiers qui
sont en tension y est limitée sur les
quais des tensions inflationnistes parce
qu'effectivement les employeurs ont
besoin d'augmenter les stocks il
augmente les salaires on reproduit
ailleurs mais c'est normal c'est
d'essayer une demande voilà il ya des
gens qui est six mois de salaire y aura
plus de gens qui vont au travail dans
ces métiers là donc ça va ça a
fonctionné pour traiter le problème il
ya un deuxième facteur d'unité de
creusement des inégalités qui est un peu
plus compliqué à comprendre les cas la
façon dont on crée de l'argent est là
effectivement à la façon dont on injecte
de la dette dans l'économie est très
inégalitaire elle tend à notamment à
fait en voulant contrôler l'inflation la
banque centrale a tendance à surévaluer
les patrimoines les et donc la plus
grande part du creusement des inégalités
peut-être qu'il est détruite elle est
aussi décrite elle est aussi liée à
cette façon de créer de la monnaie est
d'injecter de la monnaie dans le système
économique par la dette et ça je pense
qu'il ya un vrai problème de fond qu'il
faut traiter et qui dépasse pour le mans
le débat ce soir mais qui est vraiment
une source d'inégalité considérable donc
ces sujets a effectivement on peut on
peut les traiter ont peut être été à la
base il ya d'autres façon de
redistribuer l'abondance et moi je suis
un partisan du rhône universelle je suis
partisan du dividende monétaire donc
j'ai il ya d'autres façons qui me
permettent de redistribuer l'abondance
mais le contrat de travail il reste
quand même malgré tout un sujet de 2,2
d'offre et de demande c'est des gens qui
contribuent à la société leur travail a
une certaine valeur cette valeur elle
peut être mais ils sont en concurrence
avec d'autres travailleurs dans d'autres
pays sont parfois en concurrence des
machines il faut garder cela en tête
pour le salaire est aussi le prix du
travail et on confond assez souvent on
confond la valeur morale du travail avec
son salaire est reconduite toujours un
mais il faut que le salaire sur un
minimum parce que en dessous c'est pas
c'est pas décent je suis désolé
quelqu'un qui est bénévole il a un
travail qui a une valeur une personne
qui élève ses enfants qui travaillent
au foyer elle est là un travail qui
n'est pas forcément rémunéré par le
marché mais qu'une valeur faut vraiment
distingué considérablement la valeur
morale qu'on attribue le travail qui est
pas lié aux salaires je considère pas
qu'un pdg à un travail qui vaut 250 fois
plus ni sur le plan moral que qu'un
smicard parce qu'il est il est de
prévenir et donc il faut pas confondre
ça il ya une valeur marchande
objectivement c'est un marché il ya une
offre et une demande il ya un point
d'équilibré c'est comme ça c'est on peut
être contre mais c'est comme ça et puis
à une valeur morale il faut vraiment
séparer les deux vous êtes d'accord
jaune du mesnil là les salaires au fond
c'est la loi de l'offre et de la demande
et il faut pas aller chercher à
intervenir
en tout cas on le voit aujourd'hui on a
ça a été dit très justement aujourd'hui
des vraies difficultés dans les
entreprises pour recruter paradoxe de la
situation actuelle une entreprise sur
deux qui cherche à recruter dans le
secteur des services connaît aujourd'hui
des difficultés et plus la moitié
d'entre elles est obligé de renoncer à
des marchés faute de trouver du
personnel adéquat donc on voit bien
qu'il ya un vrai sujet aujourd'hui
dans ces eaux les rues aurélie trouvé
qui a l'air d'avoir des problèmes qui
n'entend plus rien mais continuer
pendant ce temps-là contenu oui c'est ce
que je disais donc c'est que on a une
difficulté liée à la pénurie de
compétences et pour répondre à madame
trouvait précisément une des indes est
vrai sujet aujourd'hui c'est comment
créer davantage de richesse il s'agit
pas simplement de taxer les richesses
qui sont créés mais de regarder comment
on en produit davantage il faut jamais
oublier qu'avant de distribuer des
richesses il faut les créer tout
simplement est plutôt que simplement
d'imaginer des taxes supplémentaires
nous ce qu'on pense c'est que pour faire
face à cette pénurie de compétences dont
je viens de parler une des solutions
serait d'ouvrir encore davantage la
possibilité de faire des heures
supplémentaires ce qui va permettre aux
entreprises de répondre à des marchés
supplémentaires et pour favoriser ces
heures supplémentaires d'avoir des
heures supplémentaires qu'ils soient
exonérées de charges et défiscaliser les
salariés seraient gagnants les
entreprises seraient gagnantes et
l'ensemble de la collectivité sera
gagnant puisque on créerait davantage de
richesses et si on souhaite les taxer
encore une fois la base c'est de
commencer par les cris aurélie trouvé
oui alors d'abord je pense qu'il faut
arrêter le dogme de la croissance
économique à tous enfin voilà coûte que
coûte
je suis pas plus pro décroissance
d'ailleurs que pro croissance économique
simplement la question elle est comment
on partage la croissance économique et
quels secteurs faut-il faire froide pour
décroître et ça je crois que c'est un
vrai débat mais là la création de
richesse en soi depuis trente ans on a
eu de la croissance et il ya eu il n'y a
pas eu pour autant une baisse des
inégalités et on a toujours un grand des
deux grands enjeux sociaux écologiques
auxquels on ne répond pas donc la
question elle est plutôt celle là
comment on partage la croissance et
quels secteurs doivent prague mais aussi
quels secteurs doivent décroître
deuxièmement sur des risques
que leur secteur doit décroître et que
même il faut la mettre dehors parce que
leur secteur un produit davantage à
titre comme macroéconomique c'est bien
mais selon lepoint micro ça va être un
tout petit peu plus compliqué je semble
toujours les savez quoi je pense qu'il
ya beaucoup de salariés aujourd'hui qui
en sont conscients aujourd'hui on
travaille avec des syndicats de salariés
les ong environnementales attaquer
d'autres justement pour dire qu'il faut
une planification il faut une garantie
de l'emploi pour tous les salariés quel
que soit les secteurs qui est certes un
secteur qui conte les besoins de faire
décroître en tout cas d'activité mais
qu'au contraire on prévoit la
reconversion de la production quand
c'est comme ça qu'on prévoit aussi une
garantie d'emplois une formation
professionnelle pour pour d'autres
activités qui ne pourrait que pourrait
faire telle ou telle entreprise parce
qu'il ya de la transition écologique à
faire par exemple produire moins
d'automobiles ou moins de moins de
camions et plus de transports en commun
plus voilà plus de transports doux comme
on dit donc tout ça se planifie xxe le
problème c'est qu'on a un gouvernement
qu'il planifie rien ni sur eux et qui du
coup ne planifie aucunement la
reconversion et la relocalisation de
l'industrie ça c'est pour la question de
la question de la croissance
décroissance économique
deuxièmement sur les heures
supplémentaires le problème aujourd'hui
c'est on a un enjeu c'est le partage du
temps de travail c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui on a 6 millions de
chômeurs à pôle emploi et on a en gros
selon les chiffres de l'insee à peu près
150 mille emplois disponibles donc 6
millions de chômeurs cent cinquante
mille emplois disponibles donc vous
voyez bien qu'on a un gros problème à un
chômage de masse avec la plupart des
chômeurs qui ne qui en fait n'ont pas
d'emploi en face et est une des
solutions c'est évidemment le partage du
temps de travail hors de favoriser les
heures supplémentaires d'ailleurs je
pourrais dire la même chose de report du
de l'âge légal de retraite c'est pas
deux en retraite c'est pareil ça
augmente tentera le le temps de travail
de ceux qui travaillent mais ça empêche
de partager le temps de travail donc je
pense que là aussi du point de vue
macroéconomique il ya un vrai problème
et je finis sur la question des impôts
incluant pas d'accord avec ce que vous
dites là naturellement les salariés ne
sont pas interchangeables les uns avec
les autres
la difficulté voulons parfaitement 10 et
les offres d'emploi non pourvues et le
sujet c'est la formation c'est
l'orientation et puis c'est aussi
l'accompagnement des demandeurs d'emploi
et c'est l'incitation à la reprise d'un
emploi aujourd'hui quand vous êtes chef
d'entreprise que vous ne pas recruter
vous avez des millions de salariés en
face et cherche un job est un problème d
joue dans prix jean genet bien que vous
que vous ne me vous copiez pas et et moi
je ne pourrais donc voilà pour finir sur
sur la question des tensions un emploi
là aussi on apprenne premièrement le
gouvernement répond quoi sur les
tensions en emploi dit ne vous inquiétez
pas du coup pour remettre les gens en
emploi qu'est ce qu'on va faire on va
diminuer les droits de chômeurs
notamment des plus précaires pour vous
amener à pour faire en sorte que les
chômeurs a eu davantage vers l'emploi ce
qui à mon avis un très un calcul très
faut donc en gros il dit ne vous
inquiétez pas les patrons on va pousser
les chômeurs ouvert vers l'emploi pour
accède pour accepter des conditions de
travail qui à mon avis ne sont pas
bonnes la preuve c'est que personne n'en
veut n'en veut à ce salaire là et la
deuxième chose c'est que en fait je vois
par exemple en agriculture sur les
saisonniers agricoles il ya eu tellement
on a on a favorisé à mort le la mobilité
notamment et le fait de pouvoir aller
chercher des travailleurs à
l'international mais ce qui du coup on
ne
ne règle pas le problème en france c'est
à dire que on devra devrait pousser à de
meilleures conditions de travail mais
comment on favorise à mort la mobilité
des travailleurs internationaux ont dit
en fait aux patrons mais vous inquiétez
pas vous allez pouvoir
avoir des travailleurs employés
qui viennent voilà de beaucoup de
parties du monde et que par ailleurs on
exploite du coup
avec des conditions de travail qui ne
sont pas acceptés par droits des
travailleurs locaux par ailleurs donc
voilà je pense qu'il ya un vrai problème
aujourd'hui de d'amélioration des
conditions trail et ça ne se fera pas
selon lui
à petit bug le temps qu'on retrouve à
aurélie trouvé réaction de de
françois-xavier un niveau bas écouter
enfin oui ou la planification le travail
obligatoire pour tous a déjà existé
entre 1917 et 1989 je vous rappelle ou
en urss donc voilà ça n'a pas marché ça
marche pas je le sujet qui fonctionne
c'est le marché c'est le libre marché
c'est la capacité à créer ces l'envi que
chacun a de contribuer et de et de
profiter de ce qui produit donc donc
donc donc c'est il y avait par exemple
revers de sa vous savez bien c'est que
oui certains ont l'impression d'être
exploités mais met donc ça veut dire
qu'il faut effectivement travailler sur
des sujets de redistribution il faut
effectivement travailler sur les unités
ratio c'est ce que je dis docteur donc
donc c'est des vrais sujets je lui il
n'y a pas de débat sur le fait qu'il
faut essayer de 2,2 de réduire les
inégalités et notamment les pays les
plus égalitaires qui sont les pays du
nord de l'europe sont aussi extrêmement
prospère et donc donc donc on peut tout
à fait travailler sur des logiques de
redistribution sur des logiques de
marché intelligent mais ils ont su
concilier à la fois de la production et
de la redistribution ils sont pas en
train de dire on redistribue on ne
produit pas ou en tout cas on
redistribue au détriment des entreprises
il faut il faut il faut qu'on arrive à
trouver le point d'équilibré je pense
qu'on est on est on est pas encore
complètement la wii où il faut être mais
l'idée de dire on va faire un espèce de
grand schéma où on va tout planifié où
on va tout on a essayé ça ne marche pas
il n'y a que des expériences d'échec de
ce type de format dans l'histoire que
des expériences des chèques donc on va
pas réinventer l'eau tiède et à refaire
un truc qui n'a jamais marché en
revanche il faut effectivement
travailler sur notre système et trouver
comment est-ce qu'on est meilleur et
c'est ce que les flics dans le livre
c'est con on a des mécanismes pour créer
l'abondance elle crée des crises elle
crée une crise environnementale qui est
indubitable qui est majeure et qu'il
faut traiter et qu'on peut traiter aussi
avec des mécanismes de marché notamment
la façon dont notamment le prix du
carbone c'est pas la peine de tout
planifier il suffit de effectivement de
faire une un prix du carbone uniforme et
intelligent pour traiter de laquelle les
questions environnementales la question
sociale d'inégalités elle être également
traités et notamment la création
monétaire est un est un vrai sujet et il
ya la question du travail des deux cette
économie de l'abondance on va avoir de
moins en moins besoin de travailler
qu'il faut effectivement accompagné mais
par des mécanismes de simplification des
mécanismes de redistribution aujourd'hui
on a on a des mécanismes en ont parlé du
chômage sur des oeufs sur les bas
salaires il ya une telle complexité dans
le système dead de soutien de poids et
c'est au tour des bas salaires qu'on a
on a on a des trappes à inactivité il ya
des gens qui effectivement se retrouve
avec des situations où il aimerait bien
contribuer mais finalement ce qu'il
gagne en marche bien des tellement
faible par rapport à ce qu'ils perdent
en perdant des aides en perdant des
soutiens qui l'ont pas il est
objectivement par intérêt de le faire
ils ont plus intérêt à récupérer des
aides travail au noir bon c'est stupide
alors il ya quelques y est ça a été
améliorée il ya la prime pour l'activité
qui a été mise en place mais on n'est
pas encore sûr un système qui est très
simple et qui est très lisible mais sur
un système qui est bourré de 2,2 d'abord
qui est très compliqué et très inhumain
pour des gens qui sont dans la précarité
parce qu'il ya des guichets dans tous
les sens il faut aller passer de la fois
ils savent même pas qu'ils ont droit à
certaines il ya effectivement un 40 %
des gens qui sont éligibles au rsa qui
ne le demandent pas soit parce qu'ils
sont pas encore en soi parce que pour
des questions de fierté et de ne pas
vivre une certaine dépendance donc il ya
des vrais sujets d'accompagnement des
gens dans la précarité qui sont soumis
un univers assez kafkaïen très
objectivement et à c'est inhumain s et
déshumanisant donc tout ça on peut
l'améliorer donc il ya beaucoup de
choses à améliorer un système actuel je
dis pas que mémé mais il faut regarder
l'art partir de ce qui fonctionne c'est
à dire la dynamique économique
l'économie de marché la création de
richesse et ensuite essayer de corriger
cc c'est les défauts cas là et elle en a
et il en a donc il faut pour pouvoir
effectivement à la fois créer cette
richesse comme les gens aiment du midi
est aussi la distribuer de façon de
façon juste on fait une pause on se
retrouve juste après
[Musique]
émission consacré cette semaine aux
cryptes aux monnaies sont elles l'avenir
de l'économie
oui les crypto mené remplace la monnaie
fiduciaire elle remplace même lors la
province du bitcoin c'est d'augmenter le
pouvoir d'achat
de toute façon à la fin des femmes les
monnaies qu'on connaît actuellement
vaudront 0 aujourd'hui on voit très bien
que les banques centrales cherchent à
faire leur propre aux monnaies parce que
elles veulent garder la main dessus et
ça les intéresse pas du tout d'avoir un
concurrent qui est un concurrent libre
pécan et laisse le bitcoin ne fait pas
partie de ce système personne ne le
contrôle
ça ne va pas seulement changer les
banques centrales ça va changer le
concept même de l'état nation
le bitcoin c'est une monétisation de
l'amour et de la paix
[Musique]
le coeur des femmes est plus fragile que
celui des hommes en france c'est 200
femmes par jour qui décèdent de maladies
cardio cérébrovasculaires c'est à dire
c'est que leur cerveau artères et c'est
une véritable urgence épidémiologique
parce que c'est l'hygiène de vie qui a
fait celui des maladies
cardiovasculaires des femmes première
cause de mortalité six fois plus que le
cancer du sein par exemple il ya
toujours trois fois plus importante chez
les hommes que chez les femmes mais ce
qui nous alertent nous c'est la
progression du nombre de femmes jeunes
hospitalisés pour infarctus vous
expliquez que ça n'arrive pas par hasard
c'est une maladie qui est évitable dans
huit cas sur dix est évitable ça veut
dire que l'hygiène de vie c'est notre
facteur de risque numéro on a plutôt un
système de soins qui était accès fléché
sur le traitement de la maladie de son
diagnostic et le traitement et non pas
sur la prévention on aidera un système
très curatif 1 c'est essentiel d'avoir
l'information pour pas subir
[Musique]
on reprend ce débat sur l'augmentation
des salaires avec françois-xavier olivo
l'auteur de la crise de l'abondance avec
aurélie trouvé par toute parole d'attac
qui publie le bloc arc en ciel est avec
jean eudes du mesnil qui est secrétaire
général de la ces pme la confédération
des petites et moyennes entreprises une
organisation patronale donc on va en
venir
aux salaires et à l'augmentation des
salaires plus particulièrement on va
oublier le chômage on m'a oublié la
crise environnementale
mais d'abord je vais s'arrêter sur les
écarts de salaire parce que dès qu'on
parle d'augmentation de salaire on en
vient tout de suite à parler des
inégalités et des écarts de salaires je
suis animateur de télévision je sais
qu'il ya des animateurs de télévision
qui gagnent plus que moi voire même
beaucoup plus que moi et je sais qu'il
ya des patrons qui gagnent encore plus
que les meilleurs que les animateurs de
paix de télévision les mieux payés c'est
pas un problème enfin pour moi ça n'est
pas un problème
alors est-ce que j'ai tort j'ai
peut-être tort mais je me dis que tant
que je gagne décemment ma vie par
rapport au travail que j'effectue
tout va bien je m'en fous qu'ils ont et
qui gagnent plus que moi pourquoi est-ce
que c'est un problème aurélie trouvé
dans une annus quoi d'ailleurs ce qu'on
porte le collectif plus jamais ça où
tout un tas de syndicats de salariés 2nd
g etc comportent c'est le plafonnement
c'est plafonnement des revenus un écart
maximal de revenus au sein de
l'entreprise qui permet c'est ça que je
veux des aveux je voudrais comprendre
pourquoi moi je veux pas que les
salaires des animateurs de télé soit
plafonnée vous avez une grande
entreprise
vous pouvez justement demandé à ce que
les plus faibles soient l'eire ce soit
un peu plus remonté et une baisse un peu
des plus grands salaires s'appelle c'est
ça s'appelle du partage voilà il ya une
enveloppe données pour les salaires et
faire en sorte que vous êtes enveloppe
soit mieux répartie entre les plus bas
salaires et les plus hauts salaires et
la deuxième chose c'est évidemment
d'augmenter le smic et et là je voudrais
dire quand même qu'il ya un effet
d'annonce qui est totalement qui est un
mensonge de la part du gouvernement
quand tu nous dis qu'il ya un coup de
pouce sur le smic il ya aucun coup de
pouce sur le smic le la hausse de 2% qui
vient d'être décidé n'est qu'une
compensation de l'inflation donc la
perte du pouvoir d'achat de la monnaie 2
2% donc c'est une hausse automatique et
au peuple travail qui n'a rien à voir
avec un coup de pouce et qui n'est donc
pas une amélioration du pouvoir d'achat
puisque puisque ça ne fait que compenser
l'inflation donc il ya aucun n'y a aucun
coup de pouce sur le pouvoir d'achat
alors que les factures d'électricité de
gaz d'essence ont explosé son avec des
hausses de 10 à 15 % depuis un an alors
que les loyers continuent à augmenter
donc il ya un vrai problème aujourd'hui
de 2 voilà il faut vraiment haussé le
smic est bien au dessus de l'inflation
donc moi je pense qu'on devrait
aujourd'hui m smic à plusieurs centaines
d'euros au-dessus de ce qu'il est je
rappelle qu'à une enquête je vais finir
là-dessus de l'adresse donc du
gouvernement faire du ministère qui
indique que les français estiment qu'en
moyenne un revenu décent c'est 1750
euros nets pour vivre décemment c'est ce
que considère les français de manière
générale il faut 1750 euros pour vivre
décemment or le smic je le rappelle est
à 1250 et à tous ceux qui nous écoutent
je pense que ceux qui sont au smic le
seul s'en rendre compte en premier lieu
peut-être que pour nous c'est qu'ils
veulent qu'ils gagnent en 2000 plus de
2000 euros est beaucoup plus sûr sans
doute sur ce plateau c'est compliqué à à
entrevoir les 1250 euros rires c'est une
galère immense pour vivre en particulier
dans harry famille et c'est donc ça
n'est pas décent pour vivre donc c'est
une question de justice sociale et de
dignité de dignité de vie 1250 euros non
ça n'est pas suffisant pour vivre
décemment pour vivre de son travail
voilà aurélie trouvé est effectivement
il ya un problème pour les bas salaires
qui ne gagnent pas assez pour vivre
décemment ça c'est une chose mais est ce
que pour autant il faut
on serait plus heureux s'il n'y avait
pas des gens qui gagnait plus que nous
moi j'ai pas cette impression perse à
titre personnel comme ça me rendrait pas
plus heureux de savoir que tel animateur
de télévision wesh son salaire raboté
maintenant il semble indispensable vous
avez raison que si quelqu'un ne gagne
pas sa vie décemment qu'il souhaite
augmenter cet autre chose mais je ne
vois pas de corrélation entre les deux
mais j'ai peut-être tort jean-régis
mesnil si on ratiboise elle est plus
hauts salaires dans les pme est-ce que
ça permettrait d'augmenter les les plus
bas salaires est ce que est ce que
qu'ils sont
d'abord ça changerait rien du tout et
puis dans les petites entreprises il est
assez rare que y ait un écart de salaire
très important entre les plus beaux les
plus hauts salaires donc je pense même
que l'écart envisagée par man trouvé ça
doit porter sur une dizaine de une
dizaine de foot d'écart entre le salaire
le plus bas et le salaire le plus haut
si mam et je crois savoir et dans les
pme a certains qui est un écart plus
important la tue je pense que le sujet
peut être écartée après sur la question
des grandes entreprises
les gens qui sont à la tête des grandes
entreprises ont malgré tout des
responsabilités importantes
alors nous ce qu'on considère en tant
que représentants des pme c'est qu'il
n'assume pas le risque de manière
directe contrairement à un chef
d'entreprise de pme qui responsable sur
ses biens propres donc déjà il ya là
quelque chose une véritable différence
et puis après quand on parle très fortes
rémunérations il ya certes les grandes
entreprises mais peut-être qu'on
pourrait parler aussi j'ai pas entendu
d'autres métiers qui gagnent beaucoup
d'argent que vous avez parlé des
animateurs télévision moi je trouve ça
très bien que les gens talentueux gagne
de l'argent on pourrait parler des
joueurs de foot qui a énormément
d'argent et c'est très bien tant mieux
pour eux et créent de la richesse je
pense que mettre tout le monde à la même
toise c'est une erreur ça serait
démotivant et quand vous êtes même quand
vous gagnez le smic de savoir qu'il ya
des gens qui gagnent davantage et qu'un
jour peut-être vous gagnerez aussi
davantage c'est quelque chose qui est
plutôt motivant et alors après sur la
question du smic je crois que là aussi
il ya l'idée généreuse en soi qui est de
dire que avec le cynique on vit là il je
partage tout à fait cet avis je pense
notamment que dans la région parisienne
c'est extrêmement compliqué de vivre
avec un smic et ça doit être
effectivement très compliqué au
quotidien maintenant ce qu'il faut
savoir également c'est que quand vous
augmenter le smic vous impacter la
compétitivité encore une fois des
entreprises et il ya des chiffres qui
sont pas les miens qui sont de de l'oat
fc eux qui disent que quand vous
augmenter le smic de 1 % on considère
que vous détruisez mécaniquement plus de
25000 emplois en face et qui sont des
emplois c'est le paradoxe de gens qui
sont les moins qualifiés donc vous êtes
sur quelque chose de généreux tout le
monde peut dire oui on va augmenter le
smic bravoure on applaudit dans la
pratique malheureusement encore une fois
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué que
simplement raisonner avec des
indicateurs alors françois xavier weill
vo vous êtes d'accord est ce que
augmenter le smic ça détruit des emplois
sûrs et plus que d'augmenter le patron
du cac 40 qui lui est tout seul alors
que les smicards sont bien plus nombreux
le patron du cac 40 le seul sujet pour
moi important dans le patron de k 47
s'assure effectivement et je crois je
suis assez d'accord sur la logique
risque au rendement de revenus c'est que
la rémunération soit fait de façon
objective et et agir et transparentes
qui ait pas de conflit d'intérêts
notamment avec ses administrateurs donc
ça c'est ça c'est je dirais un aliment
de base après ce sont des effectivement
comment est-ce que vous évaluer la
valeur qu'à un carlos tavares pour
constater dans this je sais pas oui
peut-être que si l'entreprise fait il
faut pas raisonner en jeu à somme nulle
c'est ça qui est important dans
l'économie c'est qu'il faut jamais
raisonné en jeu à somme nulle parce
qu'il ya des gens de talent qui lève qui
apporte de la valeur alors
l'organisation dans les cas ils sont
voilà est ce que est ce que messi va
apporter de la valeur au psg j'en sais
rien mais en tout cas c'est bien la
logique du fait que le psg fait venir
mais si dans son effectif et qu'il est
équipé en vidéo et donc donc la question
c'est aussi pour les actionnaires de
l'entreprise ou est-ce que je vais
investir dans mes talents pour qu'ils
apportent de la valeur après je sais pas
si c'est un bon investissement je suis
pas en train de dire que telle ou telle
pdg vaut effectivement le salaire qui
apporte mais c'est vraiment là
heureusement qu'il faut qu'avant d'être
s'agissant du smic moi je suis
complètement d'accord avec avec ce qui
est dit et c'est tout à fait objective
et c'est à dire que c'est aujourd'hui au
dessus de 1,6 smic le chômage en france
est d'ordre 3% il n'y a pratiquement pas
de chômage en france au dessus de 1,6
smic tout le chômage en france se
concentre sur les bas salaires pourquoi
parce qu'effectivement
le smic est une machine à exclure dans
l'emploi vous avez plein d'emplois qui
pourraient être rémunérés plus bas que
le smic et qui n'existent pas parce
qu'effectivement l'expliquent les exclus
comment est ce qu'on fait avec ces
personnes là parce que je suis également
d'accord avec les intervenants un smic
ne permettent pas de vivre correctement
et donc donc en dessous ce soit sur leur
glace trophic et donc effectivement
l'allemagne a réussi à résoudre en
partie en terme de chômage notamment en
laissant des mini jobs se mettre en
place mais qui effectivement on pas un
revenu de l'espagne beaucoup d'argent
pour vivre et donc toute la question moi
je préférerais plutôt que de travail sur
le smic travailler sur une logique de
reconstruction des minima sociaux et
notamment d'avoir des minima sociaux
qu'ils ne dépendent pas du fait qu'on
travaille ou pas aujourd'hui si vous
avez des minima sociaux quand vous
reprenez un travail vous rendez vous
minima sociaux et donc vous avez une
association mauvaise à reprendre le
travail et en plus vous avez vous avez
vous restez toujours donné dans les
niveaux de salaires qui sont très
mauvais on pourrait tout à faire
réfléchir à repenser ses minima sociaux
autour d'une logique de revenu universel
au moins de revenu sur le départ et de
revenir c'est ensuite qu'ils seraient
pour l'instant la redistribution
constant donc faut pas rêver c'est pas
ça qui va augmenter le pouvoir d'achat
tout de suite mais au moins on mettrait
en place un mécanisme qui serait
beaucoup plus stable pour les personnes
aujourd'hui le rsa c'est 500 euros la
partie redistributif des allocations
chômage c'est environ 500 euros un
emploi et dc5 à 700 euros payés par
l'état les réductions fillon parce que
le smic est sponsorisé par l'état il
serait appelé les entreprises seraient
incapables de payer le smic haut niveau
qui est il aujourd'hui en fait qu'ils
reçoivent l'équivalent de 600 euros via
les réductions fillon donc en fait vous
avez plein de canaux différents qui
injecte 500 euros aux gens qui sont dans
la précarité aux proches de la précarité
mais parler des intermittents du
spectacle le régime lebron nombreux
régimes moyen c'est de l'ordre de 400
euros par an par intermittence enfin
vous avez fait plein de plein de plein
de différents guichets et en fait on
pour être complètement restructuré sa
autour d'un revenu socle de 500 euros
qui serait d'ailleurs valérie petit a
fait une proposition dans ce sens à
l'assemblée nationale récemment une
enquête qui était acquise et acceptée
par l'ensemble des députés de différents
de différent de différents horizons ça
allait de la droite à la gauche pour
réfléchir à la façon dont on peut
reconstruire une protection sociable
beaucoup plus englobante beaucoup plus
stable est beaucoup plus simple et donc
beaucoup moins coûteuse pour l'état
entre parenthèses pour avoir quelque
chose qui soit qui permette aux gens
d'avoir un revenu
d'avoir un salaire qui éventuellement
pas le papa un salaire décent ou par un
salaire minimal mais d'avoir un
complément de revenu qui ne dépendent
pas du fait qu'on travaille ou pas et là
je pense qu'il ya une vraie réflexion à
mener autour de 7 cette logique là qui
est qui est porté par différentes
personnes par gaspard koenig par un mark
ii basque à part une valérie petit
autour de cette logique de dire
refondons notre système social pour
avoir quelque chose de beaucoup plus
protecteur évidemment à fiscalité
constante aujourd'hui à la distribution
quand je tourne donc c'est pas ça qui va
faire que vous allez gagner 2000 euros
demain ça c'est clair il faut pas se
mentir mais au moins on peut avoir
quelque chose qui est plus plus
sécurisant pour les parcours et qui
permette aux gens plutôt que d'aller
remplir des servat et d'aller à faire
les que hoarau à la caisse d'allocations
familiales pour demander leur art à ça
et pour comprendre pourquoi est ce
qu'ils ont perçu moins ou plus ou etc et
d'avoir de se concentrer sur un projet
personnel un projet dit
je vous écoute ce que j'ai belgique vous
avez beaucoup de choses à répondre
aurélie trouvé
la première chose pour répondre sur la
question de quand on augmente le smic ça
détruit 200 points ça c'est faux il ya
une médiane mais tanya de plusieurs
méta-analyse en économie qui ont été
faites c'est à dire qu'on a regroupé
toutes les analyses faites depuis 10 20
ans sur ces questions là en fait on se
rend compte que l'effet sur l'emploi
minimes onu ou nuls voilà ça je connais
un haut niveau ça dépend de niveau c'est
aux états unis effectivement quand c'est
à un niveau très savants fonction alarme
ayant effectivement ça fait pas mal
c'est l'évangile où je vous parle des
méta analyses faites sur le cas français
un jeu un économiste comme michel husson
malheureusement qui vient des cds qui le
montre très bien sûr les méta-analyses
depuis et sur toutes les études
économiques produits y compris par le fc
eux depuis depuis 15 ans deuxièmement
sur la question pourquoi s'en prendre
aux salaires aux revenus je les dis un
pur pas par la fiscalité pour avoir
davantage de recettes publiques et c'est
pas mignon lisf la flat tax notamment
ccc au moins 5 milliards d'euros par an
en moins de recettes publiques qui
visent et particulièrement les 0 0 1%
les plus riches et puis troisièmement je
voudrais réagir sur wii et sur cette
question aussi des plus riches problème
c'est qu'on a une croissance économique
qui est durablement faible elle ne
remontera pas elle est durablement
faible et cette croissance économique
donc il faut cibler la richesse produite
en plus chaque année elle est
extrêmement faible et il faut là il faut
la partie g et donc la question c'est
comment la partage et donc pour la
partager davantage vers les plus
défavorisés et bien il faut aussi
prendre sur les plus riches et c'est pas
plus compliqué que ça et troisièmement
sur la question de la question pardon de
rehausser les salaires les plus bas en
fait ça peut être justement très
favorable à la relance de l'activité de
l'emploi c'est une pure analyse
keynésienne donc je n'invente rien c'est
kenz ccc le le fondement de la pensée de
keynes c'est à dire que quand on
rehausse le pouvoir d'achat des plus
précaires c'est eux les plus faibles
revenus c'est eux qui ont la plus grande
propension à consommer quand vous donner
1000 euros à quelqu'un qui a un faible
revenu il va beaucoup plus consommer que
quelqu'un qui est très riche voilà et
donc pour relancer l'activité l'emploi
le meilleur moyen c'est de remplir les
carnets de commande alors pas dans
n'importe quel secteur il faut le faire
c'est là qu'il faudra élever en fonction
de la transition écologique et sociale
mais met donc quand vous remplissez les
carnets de commande en réhaussant
pouvoir d'achat des plus précaires eh
bien vous créer de l'emploi et donc
c'est effectivement une politique de la
demande plutôt qu'une politique de
l'offre comme celle qui est faite depuis
le tournant néolibéral des années 80
joël dhumez mail
moi je ne crois pas du tout ça va pas
vous étonner à l'économie dirigée je
pense qu effectivement ça a été dit tout
à l'heure toutes les expériences ont été
un échec il n'y a aucune raison que ça
change ensuite quand j'entends mal à me
trouver sur la répartition des richesses
je suis quand même un tout petit peu
étonné quand on parle simplement de
prélèvements supplémentaires
il faut quand même se souvenir que la
france aujourd'hui est championne
d'europe des prélèvements obligatoires
donc on a l'impression qu'on prélève
rien du tout aujourd'hui plus de 57 % de
la richesse créée en france fait
aujourd'hui l'objet de prélèvements
obligatoires donc on peut pas raisonner
comme si on était on partait d'un point
de départ ça c'est le premier élément
après qu'il faille réfléchir à la
location de cet argent à savoir comment
l'utiliser oui effectivement ça ça me
paraît un point important et puis il ya
autre chose qui a été dit tout à l'heure
évidemment qu'on ne peut que partager
aujourd'hui il ya énormément de
mécanismes qui existent pour aider les
gens qui sont dans la difficulté
alors ça peut être du côté de l'état ça
peut être du côté du conseil régional ça
peut être du côté département la mairie
etc etc et le résultat des courses c'est
que en pratique vous avez des gens qui
ont intérêt à ne pas travailler plutôt
qu'à travailler et ça c'est gens là on
ne peut absolument pas leur reprocher
puisque c'est le système qui est comme
ça donc avoir un dispositif qui
permettra de refondre l'ensemble des
aides de façon à bien distinguer entre
ce qui ressort de des revenus liés à
l'aide et puis des revenus liés à
l'activité dans une entreprise ça serait
quelque chose effectivement le
souhaitable je le répète encore une fois
du côté des chefs d'entreprise
aujourd'hui c'est absolument
incompréhensible de ne pas trouver
aujourd'hui de salariés et en même temps
d'avoir plusieurs millions de personnes
qui sont indemnisés par pôle emploi donc
ça mérite une réflexion et pas
simplement l'idée de mettre en place des
prélèvements obligatoires je crois que
là-dessus on a déjà donné ici je veux
dire françois-xavier olivo est ce que le
pouvoir d'achat a baissé
c'est assez difficile à dire parce que
vous avez tellement de bien qu'ils sont
devenus gratuits ou moins cher que c'est
que c'est non je pense qu objectivement
on vit quand même beaucoup mieux
aujourd'hui qu'il ya dix ans qui avait
atteint 80 ans en moyenne en moyenne
c'est absolument évident que dans les
queues que derrière les dingues
creusement d'égalité qui fait que en bas
de l'échelle se soit pas forcément
évident ça c'est sûr aussi mais en
moyenne on vit bien mieux qu'il ya 10 20
en termes de son allié en guyane
d'éducation en termine logiquement le
prix des logements par exemple a explosé
mais les prix des logements et l'insee
dont il ya pas content alors dans
l'augmentation de le fric des loges dans
leurs exactions alors il ya d'abord le
marché du logement en france est assez
difficile mais ça c'est un autre sujet
mais non le pourquoi le prix de jugement
il faisait parce que le le prix de vente
des logements exposés et pourquoi ce
qu'il explose c'est parce qu'on a créé
beaucoup d'argent par la dette et qu'on
va injecter beaucoup de dettes et que la
dette fait monter le prix des actifs
c'est ça le principal problème
effectivement et c'est l'un des
principaux problèmes notamment des gens
modestes et que plus on injecte de la
dette puis on fait monter le prix des
actifs et plus on exclut de
l'acquisition de logement des gens qui
n'ont pas de capitaine le départ donc en
fait ça c'est un mécanisme extrêmement
inégalitaire sai a aucun doute là dessus
et je pense enfin moi je milite pour un
changement radical de la façon de
concret de la monnaie on peut tout à
fait quitté d'ailleurs qu'on est on a
été pas loin de le mettre en place aux
états unis vous savez qu'il ya eu des
stimulus tchèque aux états unis qui ont
été les chèques qui ont été envoyés par
le par le gouvernement aux gens les plus
modestes et ça c'est effectivement
quelque chose qui à cet effet de relance
keynésienne que coralie trouver
mentionné sans perturber le marché du
travail qui encore une fois est un
marché avec une offre une demande donc
vous avez finalement sans avoir besoin
de travailler sur le smic vous pouvez
avoir une rente qui est qui qui qui
fonctionne et ça
on sait le faire tant qu on ne relance
pas l'inflation s'est parfaitement
injecter de l'argent de façon
unilatérale sans forcément sous forme de
dette en l'occurrence ils ont compté les
dix ans des états unis mais on peut le
faire sans comptabilisés en dette à
partir du moment où on ne dépasse pas 1
seule inflation et comme l'économie est
une machine à faire baisser les prix en
réalité on a tout à fait la possibilité
d'injecter de l'argent aux ménages en
france ce serait de l'ordre de 50 à 100
euros par personne et par mois ce qui
est quand même pas complètement
négligeable sais pas c'est pas la folie
mais c'est déjà pas mal et ce serait
quelque chose qui augmenterait au cours
du temps avec le avec l'accélération de
la technologie qui est de plus en plus
déflationniste donc on pourrait tout à
fait imaginable donc vous vous dites que
le pouvoir d'achat a augmenté en dépit
de l'augmentation du prix de logements
avec des matières premières
globalement il ya plein de choses qui
est que sur lesquels on est prévisible
quand on achetait des 33 tours quand on
est quand on était gamins voilà
aujourd'hui vous avez vous avez un accès
à trois mois de 10 heures pour le prix
dans 33 tours dans les années 80 vous
avez le l'abondance en termes de en
terme de loisirs est absolument
monumental vous avez aujourd'hui tout le
monde a dans sa poche un téléphone
portable qui est quelque chose qui est
une espèce d'ordinateurs d'une puissance
fa qui coûte beaucoup plus cher que le
téléphone en bakélite conte avec l
allemand gratuit et pas du tout mais le
téléphone les communications aujourd'hui
l'obligation mais le téléphone grand
match en tenant le téléphone le
téléphone était été beaucoup de noms le
téléphone était plus cher bah oui mais
c'est plus cher que le que je parte
fonde non mais c'est un truc de dingue
la déflation technologique on s'en rend
pas compte parce qu'on vit dedans
évidemment ça devient banal mais le met
les pour trois mois de forfait
aujourd'hui téléphone
voix data illimité vous avez vous avez
deux minutes de communication aux
outre-mer ou à l'étranger dans les
années 80 c'est donc on l'a oublié mais
mais en fait on a une abondance de biens
qui est complètement incroyable et on a
aujourd'hui on a là on en a on meurt
plus de faim dans le monde demeure plus
de malnutrition dans le monde d'obésité
dans le monde que de ça oui c'est un
truc de fou et donc donc on a on a
accédé à sa tâche de l'abondance on ne
sait pas bien géré et on a des beaucoup
de crises notamment la crise
environnementale est effectivement une
crise des inégalités qui est bien réel
qui viennent du fait qu'on sait pas
gérer cette abondance mam est
objectivement on a on a on a aujourd'hui
des possibilités
n'importe quelle personne dans la rue j
bien mieux que que des puissants au
début du siècle dernier aurélie trouvé
non mais excusez moi ça m'a du tri sur
ce sujet de recherche je ne peux pas
laisser dire ça va pas effectivement il
ya 3 millions il ya il ya un grand
nombre de personnes aujourd'hui qui sans
malnutries plus encore si minuterie mais
ça n'a rien à envier à manca une part
sur l'obésité mais la plus grande part
des personnes malnutries c'est parce
qu'il ya des carences en fer en minéraux
etc d'oksana ça n'a pas à voir avec avec
l'obésité qui n'est qu'une petite partie
de la malnutrition juge tout l'hérault
médecins et notamment du fait du manque
de pouvoir d'achat parce que en fait
avoir un régime sain c'est beaucoup plus
coûteux que d'avoir un régime par
exemple uniquement à base de riz donc je
le dis voilà sur la malnutrition dans le
monde c'est au justement un problème de
pauvreté est pas d'abondance quoi voilà
sur la question de l'abondance je crois
que les personnes qui nous écoutent
certaines se disent effectivement ça va
mieux pour moi depuis dix ans sauf
qu'une grande partie des français pour
qu'elle en fait ça ne va pas mieux ça va
beaucoup plus mal et est ce qu'on voit
c'est effectivement un approfondissement
des inégalités avec avec certes voilà
des très riches qui vivent de mieux en
mieux mais aussi des profs qui qui
tirent la langue de plus en plus et vous
l'avez dit sur la question des loyers
par ailleurs la question des loyers
écoutez les associations de défenses
vieux des sans logis ou des malles des
mal logés la première des demandes c'est
le plafonnement des loyers tout
simplement je voulais juste répondent
aussi sur la question des du problème de
sur les tensions sur les emplois c'est
vrai qu'il ya un certain nombre
d'emplois aujourd'hui qui
sont en tension dans la restauration
dans quelques autres secteurs mais c'est
justement parce que avec la crise
sanitaire il ya une prise de conscience
d'un certain nombre de personnes qui ne
qui n'acceptent plus effectivement
certaines conditions aille là où les
rémunérations et sont les plus faibles
et là où la précarité du travail est la
plus forte et donc ça devrait celui-ci
ont ensuite si on avait juste une
logique d'offre demande du marché de
l'emploi qu'est ce qui devrait se passer
une hausse des conditions une
amélioration des conditions de travail
et des revenus pour eux pour faire
revenir ces personnes bon mais c'est pas
ce qui se passe regardez les salaires
n'arrive pas gouvernement a beau dire il
faut augmenter les salaires ils
n'augmentent pas évidemment parce qu'il
augmente pas le smic c'est le seul moyen
de le faire vraiment augmenté pour les
revenus les plus précaires pour les pour
les revenus les plus bas mais donc on
voit bien que si on n'est que sur la
logique de l'offre et de la demande
d'emploi ça ne marche pas on augmente
les salaires les plus faibles n'augmente
pas donc il faut bien une intervention
de l'état en l'occurrence à face tu smic
et dernière chose la protection sociale
tout à fait d'accord avec vous mais moi
il ya un principe qui me semble
essentielle c'est qui veut travailler et
avoir droit à un travail dit doit
pouvoir avoir droit à ce travail dignes
avec un salaire digne donc il faudrait
hausser le smic et donc il faut créer
aujourd'hui des millions d'emplois et
pour ça il ya besoin de recettes
publiques y compris avec une taxe une
redistribution une fiscalité beaucoup
plus redistributive est donc une mise à
contribution plus importante notamment
des hauts revenus et de la finance voilà
jean eudes du mesnil sur les tensions
dans les rues d'après aurélie trouvé ne
ne répond pas à la loi de l'offre et de
la demande
écoutez malheureusement j'aimerais bien
que ce qui a été dit soit vrai c'est à
dire que ce soit simplement dans
certains secteurs qui connaissent des
pénuries de compétences et des
difficultés pour recruter
malheureusement aujourd'hui ce n'est pas
le cas c'est l'ensemble des secteurs qui
sont concernés et c'est l'ensemble des
métiers également donc il ya il ya
encore avant la crise qu vite ce que
vous dites est exact c'est à dire tu
étais
segmenté sur certaines activités ça
n'est plus vrai aujourd'hui donc on voit
bien qu'il ya un problème collectif et
puisque je voudrais dire aussi quand
même en vous entendant pardonnez moi
mais tout va mal finalement
crois qu'il faut reconnaître qu'on vit
dans un pays formidable que la santé est
gratuite il ya quand même quelque chose
moi que je trouve fera pendant la
période de la crise qu vide
l'activité économique a reculé de 8% ce
qui s'était pas vu depuis des lustres en
france durant cette période là dans la
même période le pouvoir d'achat des
ménages a augmenté de +0 4% donc quand
vous parliez d'inégalités là il ya eu
une répartition précisément des
prélèvements qui a fait en sorte de
maintenir le pouvoir d'achat des
français et on ne peut que s'en réjouir
mais je crois qu'il faut être il fournit
est parfaitement conscient et puis quand
vous parlez des prélèvements
obligatoires qui a priori vous sont
chers
aujourd'hui on a un problème sur
l'électricité des factures d'électricité
qui sont en train d'exploser ça devient
une vraie difficulté est ce que vous
savez que sur votre facture
d'électricité
il ya plus de 37% du total de votre
facture qui est liée simplement à des
taxes sur l'électricité
donc voilà je pense que quand on parle
pouvoir d'achat il faut aussi réfléchir
taxe mais n'ont pas augmenté les taxes
mais les diminuer plutôt oui qu'on n'est
pas exactement d'accord
françois-xavier haut niveau c'est quand
même incroyable seulement 8 % l'activité
économique n'a baissé que nuit pour cent
depuis le début de la crise du coming
alors qu'on a tous fermés absolument
mais c'est assez preuve alors on en ont
subi les conséquences aujourd'hui parce
que c'est vrai qu'avec un brin à coups
de ce coup de frein puis le coup
d'accélération avec avec des stocks qui
sont vides entre temps qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui on est quand même sur une
détention à peu près sur tous les
marchés qui sont qui sont monumentales
et qui vont mettre un peu de temps à se
résorber mais mais c'est très
intéressant ce qui a été souligné c'est
que c'est qu'effectivement on a
aujourd'hui une capacité à absorber des
crises une crise monumentale comme celle
du coup vite qui a été calme une
violence absolument inouïe à la fois
dans sa soudaineté et dans son amplitude
effectivement en soutenant en soutenant
les ménages je pense qu'on n'a pas
encore complètement trouver la bonne
façon de soutenir et qu'on a on a créé
de la dette de façon tout à fait inutile
on aurait pu éviter de le fermer mais ça
c'est un autre sujet mais c'est quand
même un très bon exemple de ce que vous
appelez la société d'abondance abba
compléteront on peut tout arrêter et ça
continue quand même on peut tout arrêter
ça continue quand même et on peut on
peut même mieux le faire on peut encore
progresser sur la façon dont on gère les
crises parce qu'effectivement on est on
est en dedans dans le droit entre
guillemets d'émettre de la monnaie et de
soutenir l'économie et de soutenir le
pouvoir d'achat par l'abonné tant qu'on
ne dépasse pas une cible d'inflation
donc on peut tout à fait le faire c'est
parfaitement légitime et sur le plan
théorique et sur le plan pratique c'est
ce qui a commencé à être fait donc je
pense que voilà on progresse on aura
peut-être encore besoin d'une autre
crise pourra vraiment aller à lewiston
comprenez que par la même occasion des
gens se disent bas après tout pourquoi
ne pas augmenter les salaires les plus
les plus faibles mais on semble va
tellement mari violent parce que parce
que c'est le salaire encore une fois
c'est la rémunération d'une contribution
à la production ça veut dire simplement
que si demain vous avez un salaire trop
élevé vous allez être plus facilement
remplaçable par une machine hier tous
les gens qui travaillent dans les usines
en région et qui ont vu des plans
sociaux successifs s'accumulent la fin
j'ai visité un site un site industriel
qui a eu mille employés une époque et
qui tourne à 150 aujourd'hui c'est
deschamps c'est déchirant si on se dit
mais c'est pas possible comment on a pu
laissé de beaux sites comme ça se
réduire et voilà vous avez effectivement
un certain nombre de fonctions qui sont
remplacés par la machine et maintenir
artificiellement un prix pour les
salaires et d'ailleurs pour les loyers
c'est exactement à une logique c'est
complètement ces destructeurs c'est
vraiment destructeurs il faut il faut
effectivement répartir cette abondance
là mais ce n'est pas forcément par le
travail autrement dit on est en train
d'arriver à un monde où on va avoir de
plus en plus de travail qui sera
rémunéré un kiss qui sera qui sera non
rémunéré de plus en plus de rémunération
qui sera pas par le travail en fait le
travail et la rémunération sont en train
de se séparer de plus en plus c'est déjà
le cas par exemple à la retraite
retraite vous avez une rémunération qui
n'est pas directement lié au travail à
l'essai l'ailier un travail historique
mais vous travaillez pas et vous êtes
très mûrs et inversement qu'est ce que
vous faites dans ces cas là bas vous
faites du bénévolat d'ailleurs vous fait
du travail non rémunéré et cette logique
là en fait qui s'est installée à partir
des années 40 qui n'existait pas avant
il est en train d'augmenter de plus en
plus c'est effectivement on va voir de
plus en plus une partie du travail qui
serait rémunéré une partie de la
rémunération qui sera pas liée à un
travail et une partie du travail qui
sera pas rémunéré je vous remercie vous
remercie tous les trois d'avoir
participé à ce débat on a déjà dépassé
le temps imparti pardonnez moi merci de
nous avoir suivis et rendez vous au
prochain numéro
[Musique]
m